disgusting how much do you think they
actually care about making this 100%
unreal none they don't care at all
we've seen some reaction videos from
other professionals in the field we
thought it'd be really cool to do one of
our own so where does a bunch of VFX
artists like getting together to talk
about visual effects the best shots the
hardest shots that maybe didn't know
we're so hard the shots that didn't look
so good after all we'll give you our
perspective and maybe you'll learn
something
hopefully I thought figure I just had to
say something
the giant effects in Game of Thrones are
by far some the best intro text ever
done so here is a giant walking through
water the water splashes are perfect
there is so much complexity in the
movement and motion that you basically
have to simulate millions of particles
somehow he's interacting with the
wireless by slipper the camera is
halfway in the water and I have no idea
how they did this shot look at that
because they figure out like the exact
perspective the camera needs to be they
basically scale the entire scene and
they film him separately on a green
screen
combined with the fact that he's already
a very large dude there's two ways you
deal with compositing when you have
people one they're either filming on a
green screen or blue screen and you tell
the computer that the green is
transparent or the blue is transparent
when the computer does its best to kind
of figure that out the other way to do
it is you hire a big team of people to
sit there and cut everything out frame
by frame by drawing a mask on it we're
not even mentioning the fact that
there's skeletons climbing up them full
CG characters that's just a side thought
they probably had to animate the
skeletons on top of his like CG double
yeah which is over top of his actual
body dude I thought the scene was
glorious I loved it I mean it looks very
painterly but doesn't look real there's
nothing like it's tough to make a dragon
look real because there's no such thing
contact shadows yeah and that's always
been a struggle it's like a fluid
overload the floating hand effect you
know yeah like you got to try to get
this shadow just right that's beyond the
shadow - it's like the motion of the
hand like if the emotions not really
touching something and it doesn't it
can't rest on something it looks funky
but this is pretty good contact shadows
are being cast from light still and in
this case there's still a dome of sky
above him which is what's causing the
light and Dragons blocking half of its
the contact shadows should only be
really getting a directional soft light
from the side and the top it should be
just an even blur all around his fingers
it's like you'll see the shadow on the
top and the bottom of his fingers and
the shadow should really only be on the
bottom of singers we're literally
talking about the compositing one tiny
stage of an entire workflow and pipeline
it's actually like pretty good visitor
here they're missing the wind from the
Dragons wings as it flaps away in the
bush
and whatnot because if we're talking
about realistic with that one wipe of
the Ewings both of those actors would be
flying away that's how much this is the
problems like you know stimuli not only
are you simulating the wind on the
Dragons skin but also had foals and how
it stretches and how it wrinkles and how
the light passes through it and then how
it influences the grass and how its
influencing the dust and how its
influencing the actors costumes that
just it's too much it's just too much
it's impossible unless everything is CG
it's too much Oh dragon this is a
classic this would be called
twenty-three years old all the original
I was confused at the time between
dragon heart and Braveheart like were
they the same thing it looks pretty good
I mean the animation is a little clunky
there's a lot of mass and once again it
comes down to physics if you can just
physically simulate parts of the Dragon
only it's all by hand it's hard to make
it look real okay so this shot perfectly
demonstrates one of the challenges of
early visual effects in reality shows
are much more dynamic than that and they
actually aren't just black their colors
because shadows aren't absence of light
so I could block this soft light here
cutting them in space but notice there's
still blue light from that light and
blue light from the daylight's the parts
that are close to the ground mic right
there inhales close the ground that
should be even darker than just that
flat shadow what you're describing is
called ambient occlusion heavy and
occlusion which is basically just
darkness that's calculated by how close
two surfaces are to each other he looks
a drop boom crusty dry clean spot
there's no like highlights this shine
basically the light reflect on its rear
affecting the sky the ground the world
around them it's just the dark objects
you don't really see but still creates a
subliminal effect on services they're
something called the index of refraction
and basically the more a surface gets
parallel to camera the more reflective
it gets so if I hold this picture
towards you you can see it you can see
really well maybe there's a little bit
of reflection but not that bad and as I
turn it more and more and more so it's
parallel it becomes more and more
reflective until it's almost a full
mirror so on the edges of the dragon
they're the highlights the reflections
that shine should be stronger than other
parts of the directly facing camera but
you're not seeing any of the edges of
his scales that are shiny
should be a little extra shiny as they
turn away from Cameron become parallel
to life the shot of him going down the
stairs is the most impressive shot in
the whole movie in my opinion is that
okay how do you think they did that that
other actor there I think they just
filmed the second take of Logan in
different makeup and maybe just like me
to look a little younger I would guess
it's another guy and they're doing it's
a head replacement a face replacement
I'd say it's like some where do those
guys dinkle Meyer twins from Luca
vestments yeah
I'd say something like that so they
filmed one guy on a double and CG slot
to say that's it that's that's probably
the way I would do it younger Hugh
Jackman is 100% digital the whole thing
the actual actor is Hugh Jackman stunt
double the wrinkles of this neck yeah
it's the business like literally the
best uncanny valley shots like they
managed to digitally recreate a human
face so realistically that no one could
tell it was digital the whole heads the
whole 100% the head basically they cut
out his head around his shirt line
that's so the whole neck all the head
they yeah like that right there is 100%
CG that face that you're looking at
that's insane it's young Samuel Jackson
you're still looks a little weird no
that looks pretty dang real to me but
that's not CG replacement that's just I
don't I don't know exactly how they did
that that's young Samuel Jackson 13 mil
eject yeah we got a Mike knowledge
thirty years ago what is this thirty
years ago he's brand-new this movie came
out this year as far as how they did
that I don't know if they they just
tracked in like some digital makeup or
if it was an actual full on complete
head replacement it definitely looks
better than young Princess Leia one of
the hardest things to get right in
digital heads outside of the eyes of
course or the soul this is the mouth you
basically have a ring of muscle
suspended by muscle that's then
interacting if your teeth the way it
deforms that interacts on your whole
face is really challenging and you
basically need to stimulate the skeleton
and the muscle structure and the skin
surface and how that wrinkles to get a
good looking mouth all up until this
point it's either hand animated somebody
trying to make it look as real
possible never does they got close a
Smeagol or it straight a frame-by-frame
volumetric capture of something just
doing it so you don't to worry about any
sort of animation simulation they're
just watching you talk and smile and
sing your lips stretch across your teeth
and how it tucks in the the edge the
crooked hair cabinet is moving near the
hairs in the neck wrinkles come out when
you move your face your ears are moving
your pores stretch there's so many
factors involved it's nearly impossible
to get perfect yeah well I mean it is
the holy grail of effects making is
creating a believable human like
wouldn't need to be done to make it look
more readable it's a lot of being a
visual effects artist half it is
simulating reality the other half of it
is simulating what happens to reality
when it passes through the guts of the
camera how does the sensor blow out
doesn't blow out to pure white it's a
blot to color when does that happen
that blue glow from the lightning the
camera would never capture it like that
it's daytime meaning the camera stopped
down even though the camera is exposed
way down the point where the clouds
aren't even white they're still glow
coming through that electricity which
you wouldn't get that's not how the
camera captures light so that looks real
those hands okay this is like real at
all it's gonna look weird because
there's no reference there's no there's
no real-world references I don't know as
far as like the actual rendering of it I
don't really have any complaints it's
all about the characters design and I
think that's where most people are kind
of complaining about it is like just the
character design seems flawed the sonic
has very iconic ly large eyes and in
this movie he's got tiny little like
regular he has like actual proportioned
legs they tried to make him too much
like something more familiar with and
and straight a little too far away from
like the actual essence of the character
like there's numerous issues with the
shot that green is you can see a little
bit green in the grass and the top-left
corner there the green of his eyes is
way more saturated than the most
saturated green that's in the scene the
camera would be able to captured that
much saturation he shouldn't be as
saturated how much do you think they
actually care about making this a
hundred percent unreal
none they don't care at all
hi-yah the Davy Jones effects were so
well done disgusting
reaction to the quality of effects or no
like the tentacles dude you're actually
having an emotional reaction to what
you're seeing as opposed to a critical
reaction to the effects oh my god over
the light yeah all those negative
highlights
they're challenging you out there
they're putting a real head in a CG head
right next to each other it is a bold
shot perfectly matching the light to the
other guy the artists understand
understanding of the physics of light
are so perfect Wow smoking blown out of
his tentacle he blew that out with his
dick nostril so service getting is a big
deal for visual effects basically it
simulates light hitting the surface of
something not nearly bouncing but going
in a little bit scattering then coming
out it's what you get when you can like
see through the edge of people's ears or
shining a light through your hand
there's now his eyes are real yeah
they're they're taking it a little bit
by actually using the real eyes the lens
effects to our flaws not only is the
animation from lighting materials boss
their lens simulation is flawless though
he's going out of focus at the edges the
way that been fired behind him is being
transmitted through the focus at the
edges it's all perfect dude when he
moves his beard each one of the
tentacles have its own muscle so it
doesn't whip like hair it has like each
tentacle is a piece of muscle on its own
that's like one of the challenges with
CG rendering are details other sizes of
pixels such as for example a piece of
light reflection on the bumpy surface
like a skin and the challenge with that
is not consistent for each frame so
sometimes to get flicker or aliasing one
frame you've had that reflection the
other treatment gun and experience back
next time he's got it and it flickers on
and off you sit in video games all the
time so they have micro detail
reflections on the skin and they are not
flickering and that is a huge
achievement dude I love his little
freakin back sack Oh neck sack the crazy
thing is all these these weird creatures
on deck are all people and motion
capture suits they film the entire scene
with all the actors and then comped in
these characters over them
I know it's a lot of work imagine this
seems where it's actually raining on set
and that was it you guys have watched
three different visual effects artists
critique and review and just overall
look at a bunch of effects from pop
culture movies and TV shows
there's your scribing to the corridor
crew tail maybe hit that Bell do it no
hit definitely don't consider it don't
even think about it just see it through
the Bell just do it just do it thank you
thank you thank you why would you throw
that up on the screen